字幕: Takuma Suzuki
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私は今 このように漫画を描いていて
私は今 この漫画を描いている時に
一番大事にしているのが
いかにして人の心を動かすのか
っていうことなんです
その中で 最も一番大事なのは
「感動」です
私はこの「感動」ということに
もの凄いこだわりを持って生きてきました
実は中学校１年生の時に
私は漫画ではなくて演劇をやってたんですよ
中学校の時
毎年「各クラス対抗演劇対決」
っていうのがあって
私は初めてクラスの中で
主役に抜擢されたんです
周りを見てみたら なんと「劇団を
もう５〜６年やってます」って子だったり
「芸能事務所入ってます」って子だったりが
めちゃくちゃいるんですよ
そんな中で私 発声練習の「あいうえお」
でさえできなかった自分が
主役をやったらどうなるんでしょうか？
チキンなんですよ
毎日緊張して
「あ そうなんですか」
みたいな感じでやってたんですけど
ただ やっぱりダメ出しというものが
10回も20回も30回も繰り返されて
演技がうまい子からしてみれば
私の演技ってなんで主役になったのか
わかんないんですよね
まぁ 当たり前かと思います
だからそういう子から
ちょっとした嫌がらせを受けて
私は一時期クラスの中で
一人ぼっちになるってこともありました
でも 私は決めていたんです
キャリアはないかもしれない
でも「一番伝わる演技をしよう」って
それで私は本番の前
緞帳の後ろで がっくがくする足をこらえて
一歩前に出て セリフを発しました
そして20分間の間 演じ切って
最後のセリフを言い終えたとき
一瞬の沈黙が会場から流れたんです
そして「わっ」と歓声が来たんですね
そのエネルギーの波がこちら側に来て
私はそのエネルギーに包まれました
その時 私の心の中からは
今までずっと感じてきた感情全てが
爆発してきたんです
人生最高の感動的な瞬間でした
私はこれを「胸いっぱいの感動」
と名付けたんです
[胸いっぱいの感動]
中学校２年生の時に私 学校を転校したんです
で いろいろ新しい出会い —
ワクワクして行ったんですけど
「彼氏できるかもしれない」
と思って行ったんですけど
実はですね 私 教室のコミュニティに
入って行けなくなってしまったんですね
いつも 部外者のような扱いを
受けて過ごしていました
学校が人生の全てでした
中学校の学生だったのでね
なので学校のクラスに入れなくなった瞬間
「あ もう人生終わっちゃったな」
って思ったんです
演劇部が唯一私のよりどころでした
しかし私は 学校の顧問の先生から
こう言われたんです
「教室に来れない子が
来られるわけないじゃん」
「来る資格なんて無いんだよ」
って言われたんです
その時 私は 本当に傷ついてしまいました
そこで私は もう学校に
行けなくなってしまったんです
ずっとこのように家にこもっていました
心の中ではもう無気力だったんです
何をやっても手に入らなくて
全然どうしていいかわからなかった
でもそんな時に 私は気づいたんですね
この無気力という状態っていうのは
何か辛いこととか 苦しいことよりも増して
人を人としては生かしてくれない
ということをです
ある日 私はテレビをつけました
そこでは
フィギアスケーター 羽生結弦選手が
氷上を軽やかに踊っているんです
「なんでこんなに素敵なんだろう
雲の上の存在だな」って思ってたんです
[フィギュアスケーター 羽生結弦]
しかし彼が舞台を終えて
一瞬の沈黙が会場に流れました
そして「わっ」とした歓声が
こっちに来たんです
この感覚に私は見覚えがありました
これは 私があの中学校１年生の時に
舞台に立っていた時に感じた
「胸いっぱいの感動」だったんです
「そうだ 私はこの感動を知っている
本当はこんな無気力な状態から
抜け出したいんだよ
もう一回胸いっぱいの感動を得たい
だから立ち上がろう」
そう思ったんです
そして 私は演劇の代わりに
漫画を描き始めました
３カ月かけて１本の作品を書き上げて
出版社に投稿したんです
結果はダメダメでした
でも自分の心の中で
「あぁやり遂げることができた」
という 達成感がありました
そして 私は高校に進学しました
で 色々やってきたんですけど
ふと考えたときに
あの漫画を書いた時の感動って
果たしてあの「胸がいっぱいになる感動」
だったのかなって言われたら
実はそうじゃなかったんですね
やっぱり胸いっぱいの感動を得ようと思って
私は 高校２年生の４月から６月の２カ月間
集中して テスト捨てて書き上げたんです
（笑）
そうなんですよ
自分の年齢かよっていう点数を取りました
17点ってことですね
（笑）
でも私にとって「胸いっぱいの感動」を
得るってことの方が大事だったんですよ
最後の３日間寝ないで書き上げました
体 すっごい 辛かったです
でも 達成感はやっぱりあるけど
あの「胸いっぱいの感動」ではないんですね
じゃあこれ もっと上を目指す必要が
あるんじゃないかなって思って
「そうだ出版社に持ち込みしよう」
って思ったんです
なので東京に行って 原稿持って行って
私は編集さんに原稿を見てもらいました
たくさんのアドバイスをもらって
私は札幌に帰って来たんです
約２か月後のことでした
[出版社へ持ち込み]
１本の電話が私にかかって来たんです
それは あの出版社の編集さんからでした
「君の作品って凄い熱意と情熱が
伝わってくるんだよね」って
「だから僕 これから担当になったから
一緒に漫画作り上げていこうよ」
この時 自分の思いが
伝わった瞬間だったんです
（拍手）
私は４年かけて
この「胸いっぱいの感動」を取り戻しました
でもこの「胸いっぱいの感動」っていうのを
取り戻すために凄い苦労したんです
これは もの凄く人生を豊かにしてくれます
豊かにするだけではなくて
強さにもなるんです
もし私が 中学校１年生の時に
あの「胸いっぱいの感動」を
感じていなかったとしたら
私はまだ 無気力の状態のまま
毎日を過ごしていました
でも私は今 ここにいます
皆さんにも是非
この「胸いっぱいの感動」を
感じて欲しいんです
じゃあ どうしたら良いでしょうか？
ポイント 実は２つあります
１つ目は あなたがもし何かやりたいとか
あるいは 何かの役割を
持っているとしましょう
[思いっきりやり遂げる事]
それをできるか できないかは一切関係なく
とにかく思い切りやってみることです
それが一番です
そして思い切りやったということの
プラスアルファになることとして
２つ目
相手に何ができますか？ということです
[相手に何が出来る？]
今やっていることが相手に対して
どんなプレゼントになるんだろう
ということを考えてみてください
なぜなら この
「胸いっぱいの感動」っていうのは
相手という存在がいて 自分という存在がいて
自分の思いが相手に伝わった瞬間
初めて生まれるものだからです
そして「胸いっぱいの感動」を感じて
自分の人生を豊かにして
相手の人生も豊かにして
そして幸せの輪を広げていって
欲しいなと思います
もしかしたら それをやっている時に
本当に苦しくて 本当に自分なんて
嫌だっていうくらいの感情を
感じることだってあるかもしれないんです
でも皆さん 忘れないでください
辛さというものは 永遠には続かないんです
あなたならやり遂げることができます
私はそれを信じています
絶対にみんな幸せになることができます
だから皆さん 立ち上がりましょう
今がこの立ち上がるときなんです
なぜならあなたが今起こす行動は
世界中の誰かが 必ず必要としているから
ありがとうございました
（拍手）
[出来るよ]